378 to 800 per year per year
oh wow it is 750 you're kidding me
hi I'm Julia hi I'm Sara Nguyen hi I'm
Rena
hi I'm Jonah and today we're going to be
taking a quiz about the cost of college
around the world we both actually go to
UCLA we didn't know each other before
today I don't know about you but my
school's pretty expensive I think it
costs around like seventy thousand a
years I'm actually the opposite I go to
Community College and you're out of
state right yeah it's even worse yeah I
think it's cheaper than other countries
I'm in the u.s. she started yeah about
how much does a university education in
the United Kingdom costs per year
$9,000 $15,000 $30,000 or $120,000
I feel like nine nine yeah yeah yeah
okay what do you think I think it's
either 9 or 15 yeah I was doing leaning
towards 15 we got it right we are wrong
it is $9,000 for the whole year average
tuition fees are six thousand euros nine
thousand USD that's like that's really
good about how much does a public
university in Japan cost per year
there's $200,000 eight thousand five
hundred twenty two thousand dollars and
57 I have no idea actually for some
reason in my heart 200,000 I think let's
just go with the cheapest one okay let's
do it
twenty-two thousand or eight thousand
eight maybe yeah maybe I feel like us is
just outlandish Leone's it right
I'm sensing the pattern about how much
is a public university in Russia cost
per year sixty seven thousand dollars
thirty four thousand five hundred
dollars five hundred dollars for $8,000
if it's five hundred I feel like it
could be five hundred it's five hundred
I'm gonna go with eight thousand this
500 can it be 500 it's just there when
you think of like exchange
but what do you think I still think 8000
we can go for outside let's see what
happened correct
good job thank you no no we were wrong
ranges from 1,800 to like 11,000 USD
that's a big range range how much does
the public university in Mexico costs
per year seventeen thousand three
thousand thirty five thousand five
hundred or five hundred five hundred
three thousand three thousand I didn't
see that one okay three thousand three
thousand that seems like a nice 500
stool oh yeah okay oh wow it's three
hundred seventy eight eight hundred per
year per year Wow it's nothing speech
about how much does a public university
in China cost per year 750 dollars five
thousand dollars seventeen thousand
dollars or thirty thousand two hundred
fifty dollars maybe thirty what less
yeah I'm gonna go with five thousand on
this one I'm feeling more the seventeen
thousand I don't know why let's see what
let me see that
yeah okay why should be five thousand
for them I hope at 7:55 yeah I think
it's seven hundred and fifty dollars oh
wow it is 750
you're giving me well they're winning
they're winning so so very little yeah
that's like that really really cheap
about how much is a public university in
the United Arab Emirates class per year
fourteen thousand dollars eighty
thousand dollars three hundred dollars
or twenty four thousand five hundred
dollars I think it's more I thought it
was like expect I feel like it's like
eighty you think is 80 okay that's
really crazy
I do too maybe twenty four thousand okay
you got that I don't think it's three
hundred so I'm gonna go with like the
next highest 14.8 again right yeah we
got it cool
and we run ten thousand to 19,000 okay
so that's kind of funny about how much
is a university education and Sui
cost per year three thousand fifteen
thousand zero dollars or forty three
thousand four hundred fifty one of the
options is zero dollars and it's Sweden
and they're all like beep happy I can be
completely free I don't know I think
it's free
I think it's free yeah I'm pretty [ __ ]
yeah I feel like if someone was like
make public university education free
they'd be like well where do they do
that like Sweden sounds okay right yeah
yeah oh yeah let's move to Sweden it's
85 percent of Swedish students graduate
from universities with debt all the
awesome living is high so it's like they
live in LA but they get free college
kind of vibes but we live in LA LA about
how much does a public university in
Egypt cost per year fifteen thousand
dollars six thousand dollars twenty six
thousand dollars or one thousand dollars
maybe 1,000 I'm guessing like either
1,000 or 6,000 let's do one okay that's
it I feel like I said 1,000 but maybe
I'm being ridiculous I feel like that's
good you should try it
yeah correct Thomas says a university
education in Canada costs per year 30
2015 12 thousand or five thousand I
didn't Canada's more expensive than the
other countries you've done so far
I think it's like 12 I feel I could be
kind of equivalent to the US right I
feel like 32 thought 50,000 and not 5000
yeah I'm 32 I think it's like almost for
you I can't remember enough like it may
be like 5000 let's go to 12,000 okay it
was that you're right that's nice good
average is 4900 that's a good project I
thought and there's some really good
schools in Canada about how much does a
university education in South Korea
costs per year sixty seven thousand
dollars $23,000 four thousand five
hundred dollars or $13,000
maybe 67 hey I don't think so well sure
I don't know I'm gonna say 4500 I'm
gonna agree with you okay let's see the
average is five five thousand dollars
about not 67 that somebody is projecting
in Chile it's either seven thousand six
hundred nineteen thousand two thousand
or fifteen thousand I'm gonna go with
two thousand but like 7600 is so
specific you're trying to be safe yeah
mm just like that's it you're probably
right but like I don't know I don't know
[Music]
okay cool an average a year of college
in Chile costs seven thousand six
hundred fifty four dollars oh that's not
that's not terrible this one we should
get about how much does a public
university in the united states cost per
year fifty thousand dollars twenty one
thousand dollars a hundred of $5,000 and
$10,000 it depends on if you're in
in-state or out-of-state I know that I
think like public it's like twenty one
thousand public university I think is
twenty one thousand right and I got what
you say I know it I really don't know
yeah okay cool but I private
institutions it's 48 thousand we got
eight hundred swamp goes all you okay I
just I you're not really good Donna 3.55
out of 12
honestly I'm considering it free
education nice country they're pretty
chill day I wish
[Music]